welcome back okay we've been talking
about data-driven model identification
for control where you have access to
full state measurements okay and we
outlined essentially a number of
different strategies where you can
either identify linear models fully
nonlinear models or these kind of hybrid
Koopman models that are linear
representations of nonlinear systems and
we talked about doing this with
data-driven regression so I like just
showing kind of a basic diagram of how I
see this all happening okay so here's a
picture of the dynamic mode
decomposition d-md
and I've essentially kind of outlined
these various data matrices that you
would you would build so I have these
blue matrices X and X Prime these are
measurements of my system evolving in
time and I could use linear regression
to solve for the best fit a operator
that map's X to the next time step X
prime okay
this is standard dynamic mode
decomposition and what I'm showing over
here is this idea that you know if I
have really high dimensional
measurements the first thing I might do
is I might do some dimensionality
reduction on these measurements X
something like a singular value
decomposition and then I might do my
little regression on these reduced
dimensionality reduced representations
over here okay so the idea is if I had a
big big data matrix X let's say this was
a simulation of a fluid flow evolving so
there were millions of records in each
column and I only have a few hundred
snapshots in time so X is really really
tall and skinny then this a would be
gigantic it would be million by million
and that's prone to overfitting and it's
also very expensive to compute so what I
might do is I might compute the dominant
coherent structures of this data with
the singular value decomposition and
then do the regression on those reduced
coordinates so that's called also in
fluids called proper orthogonal
decomposition and so I might do my DMD
regression on PID coefficients okay
again standard DMD now you know you can
also
send this to the Koopman analysis this
is what's known as extended DMD where
now what I'm going to do is build an
Augmented set of measurements Y so this
is even bigger than my original state
and this is augmented with nonlinear
measurements of my system this is the
extended DMD regression and I can get an
even bigger regression operator kay and
again I might want to do this in some
dimensional some reduced coordinate
system and then the third approach for
system identification and notice that
there's no control there's no plus bu in
any of these so I'm just showing you
what exists now and then what we're
going to do to extend these two control
so we also have this Cindy this sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics
regression and so essentially what we do
is we build this this library of
possible right hand side functions for X
dot equals f of X so we build a library
a nonlinear library of candidate
functions for f of X and then what we do
is we find the sparse set of
coefficients the sparse linear
combination of those those nonlinear
functions that agrees with my data X
dots okay that's just the the Cindy
algorithm and again you can do this on p
OD coordinates or SVD coordinates if you
have really big data like a fluid okay
and so what we're talking about now is
extending all of these methods to
include actuation and control so a plus
bu and so here you can see now in the
right this DMD with control if I not
only had X Prime and X but I also had
this green OOP salon over here then I
could simultaneously identify a and B
matrices that get this actuated
dynamical system okay so this is very
useful if you actually can measure your
input signal OOP salon or you in time
and form it into a matrix
OOP salon you can solve simultaneously
for your a and your B matrices and you
can disambiguate the effect of the
dynamics the a matrix from the effect of
actuation and control the B matrix okay
so that's very important extension is
DMD to DMD control and that's actually
the first
tension that happens so Josh Proctor did
that early on an extended DMD to handle
inputs and control and since then it
became pretty clear that you could also
do this in the Koopman and Cindy
frameworks so again if you have these
epsilon measurements you can augment
your libraries with with the control
inputs you and you can simultaneously
find not just the internal state
dynamics but how control affects those
and similarly down here in the cindy
framework i can build a library of
candidate functions not just of X but of
you so instead of functions of X like X
x squared X cubed I can have joint
functions of the state and control like
X U and u squared and cosine of X plus u
things like that and I can find the
Sparsit
linear combination X dot equals f of X
comma u ok so this is kind of just a
pictorial overview of how this
data-driven regression framework works I
can have linear models I can have these
linear representations of nonlinear
systems or I can have fully nonlinear
models these all exist and were
developed in the past but now what we're
going to do is extend these to handle
inputs and control over here and then
we're going to use those models for
example with model predictive control
for actual high dimensional complex
possibly nonlinear systems okay thank
you